tonight on the new reality
he got infected with kobet 19
unfortunately
and i see it as preventable covin's
second wave has
once again ravaged ontario's long-term
care homes
it's absolutely ridiculous that it's
taking that long
to give the first dose you're saying the
government is complicit
in those deaths absolutely
it is revolutionary technology this is
the first time that an mrna vaccine is
going to be
deployed at a global level its strength
is its ability to harness the power of
the body's own immune system
the first question is are you okay and
then the second question is
should i get this vaccine and i always
answer with yes
[Music]
hello i'm donna friesen welcome to the
new reality
we're in the race of a lifetime getting
a covid19 vaccine into arms while
fighting back a second wave which
threatens to overwhelm our hospitals and
long-term care homes
it's a test of logistics planning and
execution
while provinces like alberta and pei
have already vaccinated the most
vulnerable those in long-term care homes
ontario has come under fire for
unnecessary delays
cue jumpers and thousands of doses still
sitting in freezers
carolyn jarvis delves into what happened
and why
and asks are we ready for the millions
of doses
that start arriving in the spring
there are two times in covid's second
wave when kristen hunter has cried
the first when she learned with relief
the vaccine had arrived in ontario
the second when she heard it didn't
reach her father in time
he got infected with copin covid19
unfortunately
on january the 8th and i see it as
preventable given that though that
vaccine was possible to be in
his arm before he got infected
ontario has had enough doses in hand to
provide the first shot to all long-term
care home residents
those dying in the greatest numbers
since the end of december
but it doesn't expect to reach all of
them until mid-february
if we had the will to get these
into long-term care we would make it
happen kristin's dad john
is 65. for now he's escaped coed's grasp
with a slight fever and cough
but with heart disease diabetes and
dementia he's high risk
and things could change at any moment i
hope it doesn't mean that he becomes so
sick that he dies but
that's a possibility given his health
issues
i really think that we're deliberately
actually
killing people with these with this
political inaction and a lack of will
dr samir sinha is the director of
geriatrics at mount sinai and university
health network hospitals in toronto
we only have 626 homes we have 72 000
people we know where they are
and we've had enough vaccine to
vaccinate all of them from december 21st
but since that date
we've had over 400 people die in these
homes
including two staff members you're
saying the government is complicit
in those deaths absolutely this is what
we're calling a senate side
covin's second wave has once again
ravaged ontario's long-term care homes
the province has said long-term care
residents and workers would be
prioritized for vaccines
alongside essential caregivers health
care workers and
first nation communities but while
provinces like alberta
and pei completed first doses for all
long-term care residents by mid to late
january
ontario still had thousands to go let's
turn the narrative around and say
we have 626 orphanages in ontario
and there's a horrible virus that's
attacking children especially in these
orphanages there's 72 000 of them we
have all their addresses we know where
they are
and we have enough vaccine we'd move
heaven and earth
that's the premier's own words we'll do
everything possible to protect these
people we will put an iron ring around
ontario's covet 19 vaccine campaign has
been about
critical decisions and equally critical
pivots
one of the first was its decision to put
its vaccination hubs in 19 hospitals
across the province
the pfizer biontech vaccine needed ultra
cold freezers
and initially the guidance was that it
shouldn't be moved
dr isaac bogash is an infectious disease
specialist and member of ontario's
vaccine task force
there was credible concern
about moving the vaccine that if you
move it around and actually if you
defrosted it and agitated and shook it
up it would denature it
for the first two weeks long-term care
workers came in for shots
but most residents couldn't access it
quebec by contrast chose a different
route
instead of entirely using hospitals it
put half its vaccination sites right
inside
long-term care homes and by mid-january
with fewer doses supplied
it had provided first shots to thousands
more long-term care residents
than ontario so yeah there's clear bumps
on the road there were clear
hurdles and some missteps a game changer
came december 18th
when pfizer broadened its transportation
guidelines
allowing the vaccine to be moved british
columbia adjusted course within days
shipping it into long-term care homes
but it would take ontario until january
5th to do the same all canadians
including me are frustrated to see
vaccines in
freezers and not in people's arms
ontario's freezers were filling up with
doses
what's more it took a break from
vaccinations for christmas and boxing
day
in einstein it was the wrong decision in
response ontario made its first
pivot it said it would stop reserving
second doses
and would prioritize speed over
perfection
so like things are really happening
could they happen faster
absolutely but there is some significant
progress and quite frankly that that is
going to save lives
by this point there was also a second
vaccine in play
moderna's which had fewer constraints
but this new strategy of speed
came with a cost in the rush to
vaccinate
some hospitals allowed non-patient
non-patient-facing employees to get the
shot
this email from osler health invites any
back-office administrative staff or
volunteer
another from the university health
network said all researchers are
eligible
frontline doctors and nurses across the
province who were hearing of this
while waiting for their vaccine became
incensed
speed over precision is not what we were
hoping to see
and it's certainly not fair dr diana
ahmed works at the brantford general
hospital
as well as in long-term care but there's
got to be an
order and a fairness to how this vaccine
is rolled out
and there's got to be accountability for
the complete
circus of rollout that occurred at usler
and university health network
kevin smith is the president and ceo of
the university health network
this was a one-time event that where
there was some additional vaccine left
over
at one of our peer hospitals smith says
the decision was made
only after frontline workers were
offered the vaccine
and there was a risk 250 doses might go
to waste
i'm in no way suggesting that that's the
right approach going forward
going forward we absolutely need to do
this on a risk stratified basis
a spokesperson for osler health said
they are following the provincial
guidelines
but that in addition to patient-facing
staff vaccines are also being
administered to hospital staff
physicians and volunteers who spend time
within our hospitals
when doses are available we've got our
vaccination
priorities wrong and i think the issue
is we simply left it up to the hospitals
in order to get the vaccines out
biostatistician ryan imgrent
advises public health units in ontario
phase one is the phase where
you need to be vaccinating the most
vulnerable people
in ontario those that will succumb to
covet 19
those that will be hospitalized with
covet 19
those that will put a stress on our
health care system
ontario did exceed its target of
vaccinating all long-term care residents
in hot spot areas
earlier than its january 21st target
the rest of the province is supposed to
be done by february 15th
you're shaking your head it's absolutely
ridiculous that it's taking
that long to give the first dose to all
long-term care facility residents here
in ontario
while pfizer and moderna underscore the
need for two doses for its vaccines to
be effective
clinical trials showed an immune
response 12 and 15 days respectively
after the first dose so that's why it's
so im
it's so important that we get out that
first dosage into people
right away one month after the first
shipment of vaccine arrived in canada
the head of ontario's vaccine task force
retired general rick hillier
okay announced a second crucial pivot
long-term care home residents would be
the near sole
focus for vaccination the only needles
in the in the next
four weeks almost exclusively will go
into the arms of those residents and
essential caregivers and long-term care
homes across ontario
and for second needles because that's
all the vaccines we have
all the vaccine ontario has because
pfizer announced that same day
shipments to canada would be reduced for
the next four weeks
it was a major blow just as ontario was
ramping up vaccinations
we would have loved to have those
vaccines going out to the long-term
carols earlier faster quicker
if we don't have them we can't do that
so we're not wasting any of the time we
just don't have the vaccines to get to
it earlier
the next chapter in the vaccine campaign
will happen this spring
when substantial shipments start
arriving we want to do more vast
mass vaccination sites around the
province you know 50 or 60 or or more of
them
and ramp that up we are going to include
the family physicians and the pharmacy
chains
and their capacity is enormous there are
family members though of
of loved ones in long-term care homes
who feel like we have failed them that
they have gotten sick while waiting for
a vaccine that was in the province
did we fail our seniors i don't believe
that we failed our seniors
i can also say you know my goodness my
heart goes out to them
all i can say is we're bringing those
vaccines to those long-term care homes
and we're doing that right across the
province of ontario
but for kristin hunter it's no longer
just about her father
getting the vaccine it's about surviving
the virus if he could speak for himself
today what would he say
he would probably say that uh
this isn't right um that
this is unfair and this was preventable
[Music]
coming up on the new reality is this
something that's being pushed through
is this something that they're taking
shortcuts on a vaccine like this
had never been approved for human use
we've really just
repurposed an existing well understood
technology
but it's not that this technology is
only a year old
the world is banking on vaccines to get
us back to life the way it was before
covet 19 and two of the vaccines
approved in canada rely on
groundbreaking genetic technology
which for years held huge promise but
always ran into biological roadblocks
it's called synthetic mrna or messenger
rna
until 2020 no mrna vaccine had ever been
approved
but the pandemic drove scientists to
focus their efforts
and now a once dismissed idea is driving
us toward what we hope
will be a coveted free future
no one is potentially more exposed to
covid19 than those who work with the
sickest of patients
zara kahia is only halfway through her
shift and has already changed her ppe
16 times the 30 year old is a
respiratory therapist in the chronic
ventilator unit
at capital care norwood in edmonton
covid19 protocols mean fresh
head-to-toe protective gear is mandatory
every time she moves
from one patient to another they have
compromised respiratory systems and they
require 24-hour respiratory support
because of this we have to be so much
more cautious when we're dealing with
patients like this who
are already at higher risk than people
in the general population
when the first vaccines were approved in
canada she got the shot
but like many people she had questions
is this something that's being pushed
through is this something that
they're taking shortcuts on but of
course i'm a numbers girl so
i tended to kind of read the studies and
read
how efficient it was and read the
thousands upon people that they
tested on phase one and then in phase
two
and also the fact that the fda didn't
change how they did their approval
process they may have sped it up but
they continued to make sure that through
every single stage
these vaccines met the appropriate
guidelines
it was done with astonishing speed in
january 2020 when chinese scientists
identified the coronavirus they
sequenced the genome
and published the data thousands of
miles away
scientists were waiting and immediately
began work on potential covid19 vaccines
a vaccine like this using mrna or
messenger
rna had never been approved for human
use
but scientists had done decades of
research into the technique
convinced one day an mrna vaccine would
work
and this was a pivotal moment we've
really just repurposed
an existing well-understood technology
for a new indication this is the first
time that an mrna vaccine is going to be
deployed sort of at a global level but
it's not that this technology is only a
year old
matthew miller is an associate professor
in the department of biochemistry and
biomedical sciences
at mcmaster university in hamilton
ontario though the mrna vaccines that
are showing over 90
effectiveness that's really a
tremendously successful vaccine
by by sort of all historical standards
it is revolutionary technology and its
strength is its ability to harness the
power of the body's own immune system
but scientists had to overcome some big
hurdles
the coronavirus's spike protein which
forms its crown
is what makes it so infectious that
spike allows it to attach to cells in
the body
and infect them mrna vaccines work by
using that weapon
against the virus itself like a computer
code
synthetic mrna tells the cells of the
body how to make the spike protein
scientists had to find a way to inject
it without having the immune system
immediately attack it they came up with
a lipid nanoparticle
a kind of invisibility cloak a fatty
bubble that encapsulates the mrna
and keeps it from being destroyed
allowing it to slip
into the cell once inside the mrna is
released
and the cell starts building the spike
protein mimicking a covid19 infection
it is completely harmless but it
triggers the immune system
into creating antibodies against the
coronavirus
if the person gets infected those
antibodies prevent the virus from
entering the cell
by attaching themselves to the spike
proteins
that's what creates immunity adding
this additional sars cov2 spike protein
mrna in our cells is like adding a drop
of water into the ocean
the cells don't see this as anything
different from what they're already
bursting with anyway and contrary to a
myth circulating on social media
the vaccines cannot and do not alter
your genetic makeup your dna
it's not something that's capable of
changing the dna
in our cells dna makes mrna but mrna
does not
make or manipulate dna there is a
canadian connection to the creation of
the vaccine
in this vancouver lab tom madden and his
team at acuitis therapeutics
helped create one of the key ingredients
in the pfizer biontech vaccine
those lipid nanoparticles early
2020 we sort of realized the potential
threat
from covid19 and so we discussed with
biontech that a vaccine against covid19
is really something we should be working
on as quickly as possible
both companies could work off existing
technology to get the kovid 19 vaccines
out faster
that's the beauty of this is is
everything could stay the same
and you simply have a tweaked messenger
rna
that exactly encodes the new variants
nothing else changes
even before covid mrna technology was
being tested on other infectious
diseases
such as ebola zika virus and influenza
cancer cells also make proteins that can
be targeted by
mrna vaccines the world could be on the
cusp
of a new era in vaccinology i'm very
hopeful
that this is just the first example of a
messenger rna vaccine
that will have global impact and there
will be
others that also making a big
contribution to medicine in the future
i think we're going to see a massive
explosion
in mrna vaccines that are widely
available over the course of the next
five to ten years
the vaccines went through rigorous human
clinical trials in tens of thousands of
people
before they were approved some did
experience mild
short-lived side effects like pain at
the site of injection
body chills feeling tired or feverish
that is not uncommon with many vaccines
yes it has side effect but i didn't feel
anything my kids my daughter was calling
me
mommy are you okay i said yes i'm fine
ursula winston is a personal support
worker at a long-term care home in
toronto where there was an
outbreak it's a relief for me i mean
i needed to do this i wanted to do this
getting the vaccine she believes will
keep both her
and the residents safer
i made the decision because
the resident needs me they need us
as a team they don't have enough staff
then who's going to be there
so i made the choice today she's getting
her last dose
adverse reactions typically come after
the second shot
there have been some cases of adverse
reactions in people with a history of
serious allergies
health canada advises anyone with
serious allergies or health conditions
to seek medical advice you know if you
look at the rates of
of long-term adverse events associated
with the vaccine
and compare that against those same
adverse events associated with infection
what you usually see is that the vaccine
lowers your risk
relative to getting infected pregnant
women and those who were breastfeeding
did not take part in human clinical
trials
so there's no data on potential risks to
them
overall though the evidence shows the
benefits of the approved vaccines
outweigh any risks nothing is without
risk
but the serious adverse effects that
occur
as a result of vaccination occur at
extraordinarily low rates
the first question is are you okay and
then the second question
is should i get this vaccine and i
always answer with yes
sarah kahia was the first person in
alberta to get the vaccine
and she knows vaccine hesitancy is real
to be able to be the voice and to be
able to speak to people in my community
and to speak to other people
who have seen me getting this vaccine
and i'm able to answer these questions
and i'm able to show them that i'm fine
and that this vaccine is fine
she believes many people who are
hesitant including some people in black
indigenous and racialized communities
isn't because they're anti-vaxxers
but because there's distrust of
government and the health care system
after years of racism and abuse this
same government is kind of coming up to
these communities now and saying
trust us take this vaccine just believe
what we're saying right now
they have the right to ask those
questions and it's our responsibility
it's public health responsibilities the
government's responsibility to make sure
that these questions are continually
answered
and reiterated again and again
next week on the new reality i've never
had trouble paying the rent before
this year and i've lost my job you can't
get blood from a stone
housing and health are inextricably
linked you can't disconnect the two
things
i observe tenants being evicted in as
little as
60 90 seconds i'm dealing with a
corporation that doesn't see me as a
person doesn't see this as a community
they see it as a source of profit that's
the new reality for this week
i'm donna friesen thanks for joining us
[Music]
you